let's go to the 508 area code possible
Massachusetts caller 508 go ahead hello
that's you oh hi Patrick
this is David a from New Bedford yeah my
question is on the ballot it's gonna be
what it's being referred to as a
millionaire tax yeah now when it comes
to state I I think it's better to just
have a flat tax because obviously these
wealthier individuals could go to low
low tax states or no income tax state so
I was just like wondering what your
where your opinion on on the millionaire
tax is like how should we go about it
what would be the ramifications as fast
I believe that's where it's heading okay
so the in Massachusetts there was the
idea of putting a millionaire's tax on
the ballot last I heard the question is
not going to be on the ballot because it
addressed both taxation and the spending
of that money on education all in one
bill and you've got to disaggregate
those two things you've got to have a
question on the taxation and then
separately you can have a question on
how that money is going to be spent so
the last I heard is that the millionaire
ballot tax ballot question is not going
to be on the ballot I'm not opposed to a
millionaire tax States state taxes tend
to be flat taxes in Massachusetts I
believe 5.3 or 5.25% you pay that
regardless there's regardless of your
income that's all it is and what the
millionaire tax was going to do was
create an additional tax for income I
believe it was above a million dollars
although now I'm forgetting because
again I think it's not going to be on
the ballot you have four percent tax for
education and infrastructure it was
going to be spent on education and
infrastructure I would prefer to see not
just a flat tax and then a millionaire
tax I think if that's the direction of
state wants to go and I would rather see
some degree of a progressive tax so
maybe it becomes lower than 5.3 percent
for people earning lower incomes and
then middle income stick with
5.3% and then maybe you go with
something higher at higher incomes I
think just a flat tax plus millionaires
tax isn't necessarily the best way to go
but it is simple and I get the appeal
okay thank you all right appreciate the
call
thank you very much yeah I think he
thought that he was talking to you on
that or maybe yeah was it possible his
name was Patrick uh maybe it's on the
passport show I think he thought he was
calling um what was that F cubed for the
Ford freedom file or something like that